the vice president did snap back at
radio host charlemagne the god after he
suggested joe manchin is really the one
pulling the strings
who's the real president of this country
is it joe manchin or joe biden madam
vice president come on charlemagne i
really don't it's joe buddy i can't tell
sometimes no no no no it's joe biden and
don't start talking like a republican
about asking whether or not he's
president do you think joe manchin is a
problem and it's joba and it's joe biden
and i'm vice president my name is kamala
harris
tammy we're going to kick things off
with you because charlemagne god said
that he liked this version of the vice
president what's your take on this well
one thing you notice was missing i have
to agree she she didn't giggle she
didn't laugh through any of that and i
think that's like it sounds like a
different language her i think maybe her
biggest problem is if joe manchin was
president
she wouldn't be next in line
but when you're having to do this kind
of of argument where you then insist
that you're the vice president and you
say your name
you you're already losing the argument i
mean this is a a fascinating display
once again when it comes to temperament
when it comes to having a
really quite uh defensive uh she's
talking to a guy who's got a lot of
influence
and this is where you can really win
and take over this argument when you
face and expect that question and you
handle it with grace and maybe even with
some humor without giggling and and
really own it and push back with
confidence as opposed to a weird
self-defensiveness
and we almost didn't get that answer
because right before that her aide
jumped in
and said they couldn't hear it right
something was wrong and charlemagne the
gods didn't buy it did he
that aid is simone sanders who announced
her resignation just a couple of weeks
ago so one foot out the door and she
jumped in trying to prevent that
question from happening did the vice
president no favors but you know what's
profoundly scary here guys and gals one
of the main questions this
administration is getting is who's
running the country do any other leaders
of any other remotely advanced countries
get asked such a question does anybody
else find that disturbing and it's
rhetorical saturday kids so don't answer
that oh by the way here's another
question being asked will a ticket that
received 81 million votes the most in
u.s history uh hey are you running for a
second term
because we see a poll this week 22
percent of the country alicia 22
want mr biden to run again think about
this we're not even 11 months since the
inauguration and the funeral plans are
already being floated for team biden and
while you know inflation's at a 40-year
high that's horrific and skyrocketing
violent crime we're going to talk about
that later that's owned by the
democratic party and while the border is
anything but
secure it's this perception of this
administration that that's impossible to
to reverse the perception that joe biden
is too old too incompetent too
disconnected from what's important to
the american people to do the job and
plan b kamala harris is more like plan g
as in guy this person is not equipped to
be commander in chief and charlie i mean
there are slips and then there are slips
and in this atmosphere right now with
the president continuing to refer to the
vice president as the one in his job um
that's got to be a little concerning for
his staff
oh yeah absolutely especially in a
country uh where we get to elect our
leaders uh precisely so we know who are
who is in charge and who is making those
decisions and i think it's a
fair uh i think it's a it's a fair uh
thing for a lot of americans to to
seriously question that not just because
of uh the the bizarre things that
president biden says some from time to
time but also because so many of these
decision decisions are just kind of
completely out of touch with with uh
what ought to be be done or just sort of
out of touch with with reality um and
you know joe earlier today you made a
very good point that somebody had
decackled her and i think that that's a
very good description of it but but i
think that what was in the place of it
this business of and we've seen it some
from president biden as well where this
idea of snapping it at the questioner
and accusing the question questioner of
being a republican reveals not only the
testiness on her part and the
desperation on her part but also how out
of touch they are it's not republicans
who are uh so exercised about joe
manchin right now it's kamala harris's
own party it's the left flank of her
party they're the ones who so despise
joe manchin they think the joe manchin
is has taken control of the country and
and of course it's absurd it's 50 some
senators who have real serious
reservations about this
whack job uh proposal that the by
demonstration is putting forward that's
going to uh you know put inflation on
steroids if they go go along with it um
it it's and and and for her to accuse
this guy of being a republican and and
you know pushing republicans
because he's concerned about joe manchin
can i can i chime in with that just
briefly is that you normally you would
would have thought with a man like that
that that either she would have spoken
to him ahead of time or that they would
have known what his attitude or his
approach would have been there would
have been no need for it for miss
sanders to try to stop the interview it
just shows you of the lack of either
professionalism or that they expect an
interview to be easy but the fact that
they didn't see this coming you guys is
shocking to me considering who they were
speaking with hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else